so if he is deported and goes to Italy
will you go there with him no I probably
wouldn't Wow
what you're saying is that you will go
your separate ways if this ruling
doesn't go your way what was your
reaction to that big confession I mean I
wasn't surprised I had assumed that
that's I didn't I did not think that she
was gonna just pick up with her four
daughters are about to enter college in
high school and move over to Italy I
didn't think that that was even an
option or something that she was
considering so I wasn't surprised at all
when she said it I started crying I mean
you'll see that I started crying I feel
like this has been a long road for her
and for it to come to this where she's
stuck by him for so long and to have it
have to end this way is is heartbreaking
no matter what the decision is it's it's
still heart-wrenching wish they could
have girls especially for her daughters
to have to live through all of this and
to pay the restitution and everything
else and and to have to have it end this
way is it's devastating and it's not
over yet they're still fighting it yes
they're still fighting it so you know
working yesterday it might not happen he
might not go it could it could turn
around
Margaret Josef's and melissa gorga
sitting down with ET at Sarabeth's
tribeca in new york city and shedding
some light on Teresa Giudice is a
bombshell confession at the Real
Housewives of New Jersey season nine
reunion that she will separate from her
husband Joe should his deportation to
Italy not to be appealed I'm not doing a
long-distance relationship separation is
a different word than divorce does
Teresa do you think she sees that
difference like separate they would stay
married but they would he would live in
Italy or I can't imagine her doing
someone like that nobody's told to her I
mean I would love to spend the summer in
Italy I mean I like the Hamptons I was
gonna say he's not the worst place to me
no did you guys get to talk to her after
that big confession to kind of mean
where she was and the thinking behind
I don't know if I did it like she
doesn't discuss these kinds of things
it's not something that she's like stuff
you know when she's ready to talk about
it she will she saw me crying she'd
reached out and just said I know you're
crying I know you're sad for me you know
is that that's all we really spoke about
we didn't get into any deep discussion
it will all play out on the next season
of the show which ETS learned starts
filming a very soon just in time we hope
to capture Danielle Staub in the works
wedding to her new fiance where do you
think the group goes from here because
Danielle stay a part of this group
moving forward she's obviously friends
with Teresa
so you'll see her around what is it
about why is she's like so loyal to
Danielle she's like mold
she's like mold you can't get rid of her
why do you think Teresa has that loyalty
to Danielle we're trying to figure that
out as well I don't I mean I think I
think she does have like that guilt that
she feels like she was part of getting
her off the show at one point which
nobody really wasn't you don't want to
take money out of anybody's mouth you
know that's one thing I don't want to do
to her nobody wants now I never snot I
would never want anyone getting on this
show like you know I'm not about that
but I feel like Teresa feels like at one
point in time back in the day she
contributed to keeping her off the show
so now she has that guilt and she wants
to and listen Teresa likes yes people
and Danielle's a yes person yes sure is
the other or is he the prettiest Tracy
of the most gorgeous Tracy you're right
Teresa and threes is like you're my best
friend but let's see how Warren genielle
shakaama defeated Spade here if she's
not on the show let's see how much
Teresa I mean that Danielle is calling
Teresa that's the way I feel and
Danielle's not my type of people I'm not
interested in being friends with her I
wish her no ill I want good things for
her and her children meaning financial
success peace and happiness just away
from me and maybe across the country or
in Morocco
way across the world
[Music]